hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alban
I'm John Humphrey we're gonna watch him
her friends over at screen junkies the
honest trailers I am so excited to check
this out because I know we shared
similar opinions with these guys before
Disney's live-action The Lion King yay
Jon Favreau's Disney movie guys I just
want to say - you should check out their
trailer or Phantom entertainment screen
junkies as for never surrender it's this
Galaxy Quest documentary full-length
feature film that's gonna be playing
some select theaters this looks great
they've produced it they put a lot of
hard work into it they premiered at New
York comic-con and Galaxy Quest is such
an underrated gem one of my dad's
favorite movies I've watched it all the
time when I was younger I just want to
give a special shout out to that before
we hop into this and shouts out to the
director of that documentary who
directed the short film I wrote hell
yeah just discovered this was the
documentary about a couple years ago
these work and I was reaching Jack
always plugging yourself that's right
it's all about me oh guys go check out
my movie fights episode that was on
spring junkies recently and I was on
screen dogies news a few times last
month a show short film that's out and
I'm I'm part of the real Regis quest
this episode is brought to you by never
surrender a Galaxy Quest documentary
learn more at phantom dog wing slash
never surrender
I'm so excited check that out
Cinderella transformed a passive heroin
into an active hero Jungle Book crafted
a narrative out of scattered source
material the other ones were movies no
rehash we'll update the original by
doing the exact same thing but somehow
30 minutes longer and drained of all of
its charm how bleak is that they were
good like that you except you know still
animated but like super realistic you
know what forget it factory to the
savanna deep inside the heart of a CGI
render farm for food that brings animals
to life with such uncanny realism
someone should have realized early on
that this was a bad choice where a kids
musical since his ultra realistic beast
look dull when they sing don't even try
to dance I'm sorry Nala I came as soon
as I could look summer that's crazy
experience the story of symbols an
aristocrat
one last time or at least until execs
raised concerns about q3 2029 revenue
projections this is an entitled Veilside
who loves to bully subordinates but when
his dad loses his grip on the Royal
protection racket he'll take around in
the jungle for a few years while the
women hold everything together yeah then
Venus society's permanent underclass
back to the ghetto where they belong Wow
no you play a lot different if we ever
saw a lion rip his dinners guts out loud
scream for mercy but then kids might get
confused with so much more than
celebrities doing a table read of The
Lion King
well Annie plays on mute in the
background they also get to do some
white dick like James Earl Jones who for
a guy who's almost 90 sounds like a guy
who's almost 80 everything the light
touches of Kingdom they probably stayed
in the final cut because every adult is
asleep by the time he shows up it's a
meaningless line of indifference rope
Authority
Hey beyoncé Knowles Carter's many
glorious beyond systems whether it's one
of her motivational Beyonce's you are
our queen you have to take your place as
king this is your responsibility
you're not the symbol I remember if you
want to get him you have to get through
us are you with me lions thanks don't
look it's good context its formation
from human the important thing to
remember is that these are just
observations about Beyonce combined with
some white work play they are not I
repeat not jokes at our expense I tell
you my family's a key and I'm money on
things they already own that started
with a near-perfect film but grab
critical failure out of the jaws of
success like why would you turn be
prepared into spoken word the need for a
different dream he can sing I've be able
to sing better than Jeremy Irons
actually for another spin on the highest
version but we're an original story is
born classic crabs out some corrective
video sequels remakes it with a bunch of
CGI for the next generation watches
butter critics decried the state of
modern cinema and less all the way to
the bank to do it all again
yes Disney we know you're selling us the
same ball crap over and over until we
stop paying for it but you don't have to
rub it in our faces story
Oh going through puberty Lord of war
destinies was nice forest forest uh well
I'll be a monkey and also an uncle
avoiding rumors of Timon and Pumbaa
being a gay couple by giving one of them
a kid ah I don't even notice that this
me is a huge problem telling day and
night apart click the Box on the left to
learn more about never surrender here's
honest trailer nice I'm bad and that's
good I will never be good and that's not
bad mr. Sandman bring me a dream
demonetised for that song I was kind of
surprised by the amount of outrage that
this movie yet right there right keep
going don't mind me anymore I'm gonna be
looking at this no than a hazard of John
we care about professional Oh totally
Marc Fernandez that colliders gonna fire
us if we don't
I was kind of surprised by the amount of
wood I could only registers outrage how
many people were pissed about you know
the idea that they sing can you feel the
love tonight but it was like daylight
yeah I get it it's distracting and it
was not the best choice but people were
so pissed about it was this a real issue
I missed this outrage this III heard a
lot outrage though not that it was like
the biggest complaint even people like
this because you know in photo real
animation day for night just isn't as
appealing and even though you have
complete control over the exposure color
range etc you know yeah I really gotta
get those daylight hues to make
we can't do this exactly like the
animated we're gonna do this different
here's what we can do different times of
day to that point though I actually
don't get why they put it in the day I
feel like naturally CGI like them this
level looks better with a nighttime
exposure
that's why films often look so dark with
every pass the CGI now that's because
you blend it in and it looks better I
can't tell if it's like the quality of
whatever the export was on the screen
Chucky's on its trailer video but it had
me concerned that the effects will not
age well because for some reason looking
at a context there times like oh this is
bringing me back to when I first saw the
trailer footage of this looks kind of
creepy and the second part is well this
age well well like in ten to twenty
years will the effects of these lions
look real still because in the theaters
there were times were look very real
which was kind of eerie the uncanny
valley is the term that people keep
saying for it now I'm concerned that in
10-15 years
I'm concerned this is a real this
upsetting emotion that I haven't really
worried about that we have to finishing
sleep but then Disney could always
rerelease this one in 20 years with
updates especially get what you're
saying I don't think it necessarily
makes the effects look less technically
proficient like I still think that if
you go back and watch the movie and slip
into its artifice yeah there's still
some amazing looking stuff but I think
this goes to highlight especially when
you take moments out of context and run
them together that the effect doesn't
completely marry to the story and the
voice acting they're happening within
them so I feel like the effects
themselves like props to the animators
that still looks beautiful yeah there
will be better effects this will I'm
sure age in a way where you'll be able
to very much tell it was a CG creation
but yeah I mean it just highlights that
fact that making it photo real takes a
lot of the whimsical charm out of it and
without making an adjustment and the
tone for that it makes for a weird
experience it's funny because I didn't
hear that complaint before we watched it
at the press screening we saw it I
didn't hear about how the photo realism
actually detracts especially from the
musical numbers they pointed out how
they don't even dance and I was like oh
yeah they don't they don't do all the
dancing yeah there's a lot of like
characterization that gets taken out and
a lot of the emotive of the face and we
talked about that and that was one of
the first things I was noticing as I was
experiencing this movie yet though this
movie still seems to really click with a
lot of audiences people really love it I
think there's something that's just
generally impressive about I mean they
showed that one slide of the Rotten
Tomatoes score and the audience score
was significantly higher and I think
that maybe a general audience isn't
quite as demanding in terms of what this
means for the overall scope of cinema
because you know they brought that up to
about like critics decrying the state of
things but I don't know I think there is
a certain novelty that people just do
get so excited to see this story
realized if photo realistically but even
like the energy and the emotion not
being as palpable and surprised it still
does click with audiences yeah but you
know we've we've covered all that
no we haven't we gotta cover it more we
gotta cover it again repeat ourselves
yeah I will say I love the be all who
ever wrote that Vyasa jokes so it's
accurate value by family safety and I'm
saying this of my own free will so
accurate yeah you gotta cover your bum
never go after pol I don't have to Queen
they clarify yeah you do not attack
Beyonce and I also think they're
starting credits bit was one of the best
I've done like that was that was really
funny the puns on all the voice of yours
must be great artist trailer
good job screen junks John Bailey and
John Bailey good job on the vo as well
hopefully they can go back on there soon
guys you can subscribe to screen jockeys
keep a lookout for never surrender and
you can subscribe to the real rejects
please click that notification where
i'll get notified whenever we got a
youtube video up and i like to end this
with a page of the day shout out to
Chris wolof Chris we've been talking
about patreon again as of late you were
ignoring me for quite a while and now
you are back in my life and Chris he
takes care of a lot of cats just like
myself
him and I have that in common little
lions see how I'm making this blend with
the rest of the video that's what I do
also Chris is
getting very politically involved lately
where he is from it is one of the top 5%
crime rated cities in America
whoa you gotta clean that up man he is
going to you are gonna have a son who
will save the kingdom everything the
light touches wherever you live again
which my very complex is very common
which are the most crime riddled cities
New Orleans Michigan that's right
North Dakota yeah don't care North
Dakota Chris and then moved to South
Dakota clean that one up too many
seriously he was laying out some very
specific details of a lot of what's been
going on and how he's been getting
involved in what he wants to help change
so Chris you have a great heart
but once everything is all squared away
once you save your city I really hope
you increase your pledge because that's
what matters most you shouldn't be
putting your money towards those in
poverty should be putting your money
towards we are in power our patreon page
the infrastructure of the real rejects
needs updating just you know get a
priority strip do your part be a citizen